star-crossed love between an elf and a
human a wizard-like stranger and a
world-destroying oath the rings of power
is filled with subtle details only true
fans will recognize
spoilers ahead
it doesn't take long for subtle
references to start showing up in the
rings of power in fact there's one that
appears during the show's prologue as
galadriel narrates about her fallen
brother finrad felagund we see his
corpse lying on a table under a cloth
his arms are out and his flesh is
scarred with numerous wounds
the video highlights one of these cuts
specifically the mark that sauron puts
on him sauron's brand isn't canon in the
source material the dark lord doesn't go
around burning a sign into people's
flesh
but he does leave quite a few marks on
the heroic finrod in the silmarillion
finrad helps the heroes baron and
luthien in their quest to reclaim one of
the titular hallowed jewels called the
silmarils in the process he and his
companions are captured by sauron the
villain who isn't the dark lord yet
kills off the group one at a time using
werewolves as one of the werewolves
makes for baron finrod uses all of his
power to defeat it though his wounds
were mortal those scratches aren't from
a scrape in battle they're not from
swords or spears or arrows those are
bona fide dying werewolf wounds
another easter egg tucked into the early
moments of the rings of power appears
when several elves draw their swords
together in quick succession four fans
familiar with tolkien's lore the scene
immediately brings to mind the famous
oath of feyenoor from the similarillion
galadriel's brother finrod is amongst
them which is out of place considering
the source material but otherwise
everything lines up the event while
skimmed over in the prologue of the show
is a watershed moment in middle earth
history the oath is taken by the famous
elvish character feyenoor and his seven
sons it's an irrevocable oath that leads
to a lot of tragedy
and if it is the oath of feanor then
finrod shouldn't be there but the
setting and actions however briefly
they're depicted seems to be a direct
nod toward the oath that is so critical
to the stories that follow the rings of
power doesn't have access to the
silmarillion which is probably why its
prologue is so quick and non-specific it
skims over many of the major events that
take place in that book
some are easy to spot like the oath of
feyenoor others seem to be a murky
mashup of multiple events presented at
the same time including a series of
battles and violent conflicts these
start with a shot of a dragon throwing a
giant eagle to the ground in a blaze of
fire
this is an event that could have only
happened during the earth-shattering
age-ending war of wrath right before the
rings of power starts
that's the battle where morgoth the
first dark lord is finally defeated when
galadriel picks up a helmet and puts it
into a gigantic pile of other helmets
the scene calls another battle to mind
one of the most tragic events of the
first stage of middle earth history is
called the battle of unnumbered tears
after the battle which goes badly for
the army of elves a giant mountain of
bodies is created called the hill of the
slain
while it isn't quite the same thing as a
bunch of helmets the feel of galadriel's
sorrowful experience in the aftermath of
the unnamed battlefield seems to hint at
that famously tragic event
in peter jackson's extended edition of
the fellowship of the ring glad drill
sails a swan boat in lothlorian in the
rings of power we see glad drill sailing
to valinor in a boat with a similar
bird-like prow in the opening scene of
the show a young galadriel also makes a
paper boat that doesn't just float its
sails
and as it does so its wings neck and
head pop up in glorious fashion without
going too overboard on details one group
of elves that lives in valinor is called
the teleri they mostly dwell in a place
called alcolanda which loosely
translates to the haven of the swans the
silmarillion explains that the talari
ships were made to look like swans with
golden beaks and dyes much later in the
book it explains how the elves visited
the island nation of numenor 2 saying
and thence at times the firstborn still
would come sailing to numenor in orles
boats as white birds flying from the
sunset
from the get-go bird-shaped boats and
especially swan-shaped boats are a
trademark of elvish maritime activity
when gladreal and her company set sail
for valinor in the first episode of the
rings of power they arrive at a foggy
rainy sea
as the clouds roll back it slowly
reveals a glorious blinding light which
all of the elves but galadriel willingly
enter into this isn't necessarily how
the process of elves leaving middle
earth looks in the books but there's a
lot left open to interpretation as far
as small details are concerned there's
one specific aspect that is worth
calling out
twice in the lord of the rings frodo
experiences arriving in the blessed
realm in the books the first time is in
a dream in the fellowship of the ring
the second time is when he sails there
at the end of the return of the king the
book describes frodo's experience
beautifully and then it seemed to him
that as in his dream in the house of
bombadil the grey rain curtain turned
all to silver glass and was rolled back
and he beheld white shores and beyond
them a far green country under a swift
sunrise
we may not see valinor in the scene from
the rings of power but we do see a grey
rain curtain and it rolls back as they
approach
when we first meet the har foots in the
rings of power they're running circles
around a couple of wary hunters the
little people lay low and avoid being
seen without any issues as the big folk
move along one of the harfords blows a
whistle of sorts to signal the coast is
clear this moment might bring another
incident to mind a time when deodon king
of rohan has a conversation with a
couple of hobbits in isengard in the two
towers
mary pippin and theoden all bond over
the fact that their ancestors came from
the same area of the world an area close
to where the harfoots currently live
when the rings of power begins
in the discussion theyodin mentions that
the halflings in the apocryphal stories
have some interesting skill sets he adds
that they can vanish in a twinkling in
addition he says they can change their
voices to resemble the piping of birds
while that is clearly an exaggeration it
would appear that the rings of power
writers may be hinting at how that
legend came about
the harfords of the rings of power and
the hobbits of later stories may be
distantly related but there are a lot of
differences that set them apart not the
least of which is the fact that one
group lives a wandering nomadic
lifestyle and the others settle in
undisturbed domesticated comfort
even so some of the through lines are
already visible even when the setting is
so different harfoots are already shown
with a very healthy appetite for good
food when nori leads a group of
youngsters to a berry patch their
affinity for food is on full display
interestingly the scene also offers a
parallel to the last pages of the return
of the king in that book tolkien
explains in the aftermath of the war of
the ring the shire thrives once sauron
is defeated the text says
the fruit was so plentiful that young
hobbits very nearly bathed in
strawberries and cream and later they
sat on the lawns under the plum trees
and ate until they had made piles of
stones like small pyramids or the heaped
skulls of a conqueror and then they
moved on
in the first episode of the rings of
power there's a point when marigold
brandyfoot has a serious talk with nori
about her adventurous behavior the
halfling mother breaks down how the
world works for the younger less
experienced nori elves have forest to
protect
divorce their minds
mend their fields of grain
she continues that the trees have to
worry about the soil beneath them but
she says
we her foots are free from the worries
of the wide world it leaves nori
squirming but
doesn't put a dent in her desire for
adventure but it also may be the first
time in the series that tolkien's ants
enter the conversation the ants are
referred to at different times as the
shepherds of the trees in the
silmarillion the ants are explicitly
made as a way to guard trees against
other creatures that may want to harm
them the presence of ants in the rings
of power is established later in the
episode they make a quick cameo when the
meteor streaks overhead and three ants
are shown moving amongst the trees
when galadriel returns home from her
long pursuit of sauron the high king
gilgalad is convinced to welcome her as
a hero
despite her rebellious disregard of his
orders the king puts on a celebration to
rival the likes of bilbo's 111th
birthday party as the elves party in
london the sky lights up with fireworks
that take on many different shapes some
swirl while others look like flowers one
even takes on the distinct shape of a
butterfly and flaps its wings the
fellowship of the ring describes
gandalf's fireworks at bilbo's party by
saying they included singing bird sounds
trees losing their leaves eagles sailing
ships and much more it also has the line
there were fountains of butterflies that
flew glittering into the trees
of course the question of who's better
at the craft of making fireworks is
something that would have to be solved
with a head-head contest between the
wizard and the elves but alas it's
competition we'll never get to see
after gladreal discovers that she's
going to be shipped back home to valinor
she retreats to a peaceful area of the
linden forests where elrond finds her
and the two characters proceed to have a
long talk
as they chat they're surrounded by a
string of very elvish looking lamps and
a series of statues carved right into
living trees one of these statues
depicts galadriel's brother finrod who
is a first stage hero but several others
appear as well we're willing to guess
that at least one is the human first
stage hero turin turinbar there are
plenty of candidates for who the others
could be but there's one statue whose
identity is without question at one
point the camera flashes past a living
wooden statue of a woman with long
flowing hair and a shaggy dog in front
of her there's no doubt that this is an
image of the immortal maiden luthien and
the dog huan luthien is one of the
iconic heroines of tolkien's world
she was inspired by the author's wife
and luthien's name was even put on her
gravestone she's known for her hair and
also happens to be elrond's great
grandmother the dog huan is also the
greatest wolfhound in middle earth
history he talks multiple times and even
defeats sauron in a duel
when the stranger crash lands near the
harfoots nori and poppy try to take care
of him this ends up being more difficult
than it seems because the fellow
initially acts like a child he can't
even talk and doesn't know how to take
care of himself
for those who know tolkien this seems to
point very heavily toward the stranger
being a wizard apart from the fact that
he's supernaturally powerful the whole
infantile start to his middle earth
tenure points to his wizarding origins
in the book unfinished tales tolkien's
son christopher brought together most of
his father's notes about the wizards or
istari as they're called in elvish in
that collection of facts it says
for it is said indeed that being
embodied the istari had need to learn
much anew by slow experience
and though they knew once they came the
memory of the blessed realm was to them
a vision from afar off for which they
yearned exceedingly if the stranger is a
wizard it would make sense that after
his arrival he would need to relearn
some basic things like talking and
eating add on to that the fact that he
knows a few things like constellations
who is the stranger from the rings of
power
as nori and poppy wrangle their
mysterious powerful friend they slowly
gain clues about who he is
by the end of the second episode he
manages to communicate by using
fireflies to form the shape of a
constellation in the sky nori gets
excited when she realizes that he wants
to find a similar shape of actual stars
during this scene there's also a small
easter egg that calls back to peter
jackson's films when ian mckellen's
gandalf is trapped on top of eisenguard
he catches a moth and whispers a message
to it in unintelligible language
the stranger talks to the fireflies in a
very similar manner in the rings of
power
this could signal a direct connection
between the characters could the
stranger be gandalf it could also simply
be a magical behavior that they're both
displaying this could be meant to
showcase how both characters are wizards
or at least have a similar spiritual
power that enables them to talk directly
to animals
whatever the answer the way the stranger
chats up the fireflies looks so similar
to gandalf's discussion with the moth
it's difficult to think it's anything
less than a direct easter egg
when elrond arrives in region in the
second episode of the rings of power he
hits things off with lord kelebrimbor
whose craftsmanship he's greatly admired
from afar as they get to know one
another they talk about crafting a
hammer on display in kel brimbour's
workshop it's not just any hammer it
used to belong to the master elven
craftsman fenor
while the show makes that fact clear the
quiet context left out of the dialogue
is that kelebrimbor likely has the
hammer because he's feyenoord's grandson
the little details don't stop there as
the conversation carries on the two
elves look at plans to build a giant
overheated new addition to kelem
brimbore's workshop the elven master
craftsman says that he wants to build a
tower that could hold the most powerful
forge ever constructed in middle earth
one that would burn as hot as a dragon's
tongue the subtle reference brings to
mind a line from the fellowship of the
ring where gandalf says
it has been said that dragon fire could
melt and consume the rings of power
but there is not now any dragon left on
earth in which the old fire is hot
enough the reference to a forge as hot
as a dragon's tongue is a fitting
description because chances are
kelebrimbor has plans to use his new
forge to create the rings of power
when elrond and keller brimbour head
over to causa doom to recruit the help
of the dwarves the lord of aragion
informs his companion that he's always
admired the dwarves and wonders if he'll
be able to see them at work in their
forges elrond sets some rather lofty
expectations in response pointing out
that he thinks they'll do a lot more
than that he launches into a description
of dwarven hospitality that includes
blaring ram's horns tables full of
salted pork and lots and lots of malt
beer if the depiction sounds familiar
it's because gimli talks about the same
kind of dwarven welcome thousands of
years later during the lord of the rings
in the fellowship of the ring as fruito
and company enter moria kimley warns
legolas to prepare for the fabled
hospitality of the dwarves adding what
the elf should expect to find waiting
for him
roaring fires
malt beer
red meat off the bone tying these
references together creates some
continuity between the two distinctly
different versions of middle earth both
may be their own adaptations but when it
comes to dwarf and hospitality
everyone's on the same page
the dwarves have an interesting creation
story
unlike men and elves who are created by
the godlike supreme being a louvitar
dwarves are initially formed by the
angelic being owlet though he makes them
ally can't give his dwarf sentient life
that's something only a louvitar can do
and he eventually gets around to it even
so the dwarves always have a special
affinity for alley and it shows in the
rings of power in the rock breaking
scene during the fourth references his
semi-maker when he describes the event
as the dwarven test of endurance
fashioned by owlet himself later on when
durian and elrond are arguing disa
expresses her disapproval by referencing
ali's beard for most viewers it's a
random and odd name for tolkien fans
it's a clear and well-placed reference
to the greatest being in all of dwarven
culture and history it's also worth
pointing out that the full dwarven face
masks worn by many of the guards of
causa doom get their inspiration from
the silmarillion at one point the
dwarves take on a bunch of dragons which
they could do because of their hideous
but nearly indestructible masks it's a
one-off reference and it's fun to see
the famous headgear translated into the
garb of durian's guards
when we first meet orondir in the south
lands of middle-earth he's visiting a
town of men with a fellow elven warden
while there he interacts with the human
woman bronwyn and it's clear that the
two are in love as they leave around
here and his fellow elf verbally spar
eventually the talk turns more serious
and renders companion says my point is
this only twice in known history has a
pairing between elves and humans even
been attempted and on each occasion it
ended in tragedy it ended in death the
references to two distinct pairings the
first is the mortal man baron and the
immortal luthien
they get hitched and end up dying twice
the other pair is the mantur and the elf
maiden idril while they have a happier
ending their tale is also filled with
some epic and tragic events
[Music]